welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in the third spider-man film is
now coming a bit more into focus thanks
to recent updates from the Morbius
trailer and other updates from
spider-man threes production
thank God being a Marvel fan in between
them Cu phases is like a dry an you arey
that I never signed up for specifically
thanks to some sinister six hints and
Morbius and details about the spider-man
3 shooting locations we may be learning
about a new villain Kraven the hunter
one of the best Spidey villains who
definitely deserves his do I'm gonna
explain all the new details that point
to Cravens introduction in this next
film who this guy is why he's great and
how he could tie into Marvel and Sony's
game plan for their upcoming spider-man
and spider-man related films boy the
warning in case any my theories into
being do right and ruin your life okay
much of this speculation began with the
recent Morbius trailer which hinted at
crossovers with spider-man and vulture
from the MCU since the Sony spider-verse
and them see you shared this kind of
weird neighborhood corner our reading of
this is a set up of a future villain
team-up in the upcoming third spider-man
film in July 2021
so what do we know about that film well
most likely it will deal with the
fallout of the ending of Spiderman far
from home in which Peter Parker is outed
publicly and accused of murder
thanks to mysterious post-mortem
doctored video and Jay jonah Jameson's
conspiracy news network an easter egg in
the Morbius trailer confirmed this new
dilemma with background graffiti calling
spider-man a murderer also look out
zodiac is back now I'm sure this is a
different spider-man the Sam Raimi
spider-man in the ps4 game loading
artwork my perception is that the set
designer wasn't too discerning over
which Canon spider-man he was using but
more importantly we just learned that
the shooting locations for this third
spider-man film will include Atlanta Los
Angeles New York and Iceland those first
three make some sense
Atlanta's Pinewood Studios is the
shooting location for most Marvel films
New York is where they get a lot of the
exteriors for Peters Queens home
neighborhood LA is often the location
for urban skylines all with less fuss in
those New Yorkers that leaves Iceland as
the mystery location of the for now
Iceland is no stranger to film
productions it served as a setting for
movies like Batman Begins rogue one and
Thor the dark world but one theory
suggests that Iceland's grows and
volcanic topography could be the ideal
backdrop for Kraven hunter a game hunter
known for globe-trotting
in his pursuit of his big game or maybe
Iceland could serve as the kinda
Geographic doppelganger for Cravens
homeland of Volgograd the Russia now
sure you could just call this wish
thinking by craving pans but the
director John watts also mentioned
Kraven as his ideal choice for a future
villain and set photos from the morbius
production have shown a catering truck
with the name Kraven on it and yeah I
got some thoughts on what this could
mean but first some backstory on Kraven
as a character he is sergej Kraven off
big game hunter half-brother to this
fight evil and the chameleon he gets
commissioned to hunt the most dangerous
game of all the ultimate trophy in his
eyes
spider-man Kraven is best known from the
comic Cravens last hunt when a be
darkest and most amazing storylines from
Marvel Comics but before I continue now
like Peter Parker I've often found
myself overseas in countries with
limited access to the information I need
or want because sometimes other
governments put weird restrictions on
your internet access which is why I use
Express VPN thanks to express VPN for
sponsoring this episode by the way
Express VPN is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen by people like hackers are
tracked by any third parties and can
grant you access to otherwise stupidly
blocked content like many web sites and
services are blocked in different parts
of the world some countries censor
websites and don't laser freely some
things are even more expensive online
depending on where you live I'm looking
at you airline tickets expressvpn is
your solution to this cuts through it
all it allows you to reroute your
connection to a server in a country of
your choice making all those geo
restrictions the thing in a past
expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge I like using it whenever I'm
on public Wi-Fi like at an airport or a
coffee shop to prevent those nosy
hackers from stealing my information my
collection of the Animorphs fan art is
not for sharing thank you very much
Express VPN servers operate at the
fastest speeds they have 24/7 customer
support and it's super easy to use just
fire up the app and connect with just
one click
it is the top-rated VPN provider rated
number one by tech radars cement and
many more find out how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box below expressvpn
comm slash new rock stars again
that's expressvpn comm slash new rock
stars okay back to Cravens last hunt in
a story an older Craven plots one final
hunt to redeem his lifetime of lost
honor after so many losses he tracks
down spider-man he poisoned darts him he
shoots him and then buries spider-man
and they
he assumes spider-man's identity he
masquerades his webslinger he saves MJ
but he's like way too violent about it
then two weeks later Peter crawls out of
the grave and he fights Kraven but
Kraven doesn't fight back because he
believes he has already defeated at the
Spider Man and considering his last hunt
a success he returns home puts a rifle
in his mouth and offs himself into an
open casket hello because I guess Frank
Castle isn't the only Marvel character
to listen to Metallica but could any
version of this work its way into the
upcoming third spider-man film well last
episode of rogue theory we actually went
into a bunch of different sinister six
lineups but here right now is my theory
for how this could all come together so
spider-man part from home left Peter
Parker in a world of [ __ ] publicly
branded as a psychotic abuser of Iron
Man's tech and a murderer of the
murdered hero Mysterio Quentin Beck
whose team of operatives is still very
much at large there's even some evidence
to suggest Mysterio could still be alive
when verifying Beck's death Peter
stupidly didn't ask
Edith is he dead he's real Becca is a
trained actor gifted that gaslighting
Peter with the timing of a professional
sleight of hand magician and that it's
likely Quentin Beck isn't even his name
because sadly given his real name to
Nick Fury's operation or even those
girls working for fury his name probably
what it popped up as a disgruntled
former Stark employee and not the
transdimensional warrior he claimed to
be whatever is left of mysterious
operation is clearly in coordination
with J jonah Jameson's Daily Bugle net
that's actually a real website you can
visit right now to read about Jameson's
paranoid ramblings including some
relating to extraterrestrial
conspiracies and those are pretty
interesting to read when you consider
that the Sony spider-verse
included the character John Jameson the
light foundation astronaut who was
killed by the riot symbiote at the
beginning of venom and canonically J
jonah Jameson's son so just imagine this
grieving father raging against the
establishment that he blames for
covering up his son's death blaming
menaces like the spider-man and his
Avenger buddies for exposing this planet
to extraterrestrial threats like the one
that took his boy enter Mysterio the
devil who tricked the world into
thinking he didn't exist who assembles a
team of gifted criminals who were
antagonized by spider-man
we saw a brief team-up between Adrienne
tombs
culture and Mac Gargan scorpion in the
homecoming post-credits scene and the
Morbius trailer suggest that dog ass
Alliance could be revisited and remember
booking Woodbine's shocker is still at
large perhaps he could bust him out now
there was also some speculation that
jarred Harris's character in Morbius
might be Doc Ock but Harris recently
debunked that theory however venom 2
will feature Woody Harrelson as Cletus
Kasady with the symbiote offshoot
attaching to this homicidal maniac to
become carnage and after all these
characters are set in place by Morbius
and venom 2 and their post credits
scenes later this year when spider-man 3
arrives in summer 2021
that would leave Mysterio vulture
scorpion shocker and carnage as a team
of villains who thanks to Jay jonah
Jameson's fake news coverage the public
champions as post Avengers anti heroes
who love or hate him get the job done
perhaps inspired by the Dark Avengers
comics and to keep this facade they
would need to kill off the one loose end
who could expose them Peter Parker and
that's where they need their sixth
member so Jake Raven off wrestling
reindeer in Iceland assigned a new
trophy prize for one last hunt a bounty
that he can hunt down by roaming the
streets of New York in an inconspicuous
catering truck boom got there okay who
do you think should play Kraven the
hunter in spider-man 3 and who do you
want for your sinister six lineup
comment down below and again watch last
week's rogue theory for our draft
pitches follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vas followed new rockstars
and social media subscribing to
rockstars here on YouTube and check out
our new Q&A series the big question kind
of our drunk mythbusters show where we
give you too much information last
episode we looked into all the gross
details of sex in the Star Wars universe
this week how likely it is that your
roommate is a black widow assassin
trying to kill you see you next time
maybe bye
[Music]